The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.MIT.edu.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Right, everyone,
we're going to start now.
So my name is Colin
Sheppard, and I'm going
to be giving the lecture today.
George is here to
keep me in order,
and I think, probably,
he'll come up
with some comments
at times, maybe--
I hope, anyway.
So he started off by saying that
there's no real announcements
except that he's changed--
he's uploaded some
revised notes, apparently.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: There were
some minor error in the notes,
so I have--
I have fixed them.
And the current
versions should be--
the one that's in the website
now is the corrected ones.
COLIN SHEPPARD: All right, so
only minor changes, I think.
OK, so I'm going
to try and take off
from where George
left it, which was
with Maxwell's equations and
the derivation of the wave
equation.
It's quite nice to see this
derivation of the wave equation
starting from
Maxwell's equations,
because it brings everything
together and allows
you to see how the--
these different areas of
physics are interrelated.
But normally, of
course, in optics, we
don't usually go to the
electromagnetic-type theory,
so we usually get as far
as the wave equation.
We show the existence
of simple forms
like plane waves
and spherical waves.
We carry on then using those
plane waves and spherical
waves in a simplified form.
But anyway, so back to
Maxwell's equations.
These were the
George, before, explained
these and tried to--
I'm not going to go through
the meaning of them,
again, because I
think you've got that.
But in the differential
form, you've
just got these four equations
connecting the electric field
and the magnetic field, right?
So you'll see that
there's two E's there.
Sorry, there's three E's,
and then there's three B's.
And then there's a charge
row and a current that's CJ.
So how we get the wave equation
from that is quite simple.
It's just a case of doing a
bit of vector manipulation.
Curl E, you can see,
is minus the Bdt
from the Maxwell's equations.
So if you take the curl
of both sides of that,
you get this equation.
And curl B is another of
the Maxwell's equations,
so you can substitute in
from the Maxwell's equation
into this one, and then
you'll get another equation.
What you get after that George
hasn't actually written here,
but basically, what
you'd obviously get then,
this is curl of this, so it's
going to be curl of curl.
So this is what you actually
end up with, is curl, curl,
curl E is going to be--
and then the other term
is going to be something--
a second derivative in the E. So
actually, that equation, maybe
I'll write it down.
It's not actually written
there, but after you've just
done that substitution,
you'll get something
like-- is this thing
working, or-- yeah, it is.
You'd get something like
curl of curl E. There we are.
Now you can see it.
A lot of people right cross
product like that, as a little,
sort of upside down V.
Curl curl E plus mu naught
epsilon naught, d2, edt
squared equals naught,
is I think what you
get after you've just
substituted that in there.
And then finally--
so this is-- this
has still got this thing,
curl of curl E, which
is quite complicated
if you try and work out
what that is in spherical
polars or something,
especially if you're expressing
E as something which is
spatially varying or whatever.
This could be quite
a complicated thing
to have to work out.
But anyway, but the-- you can
get it into a slightly more
usable form--
often we do this--
by using this
identity, curl curl E
is equal to grad of div
E minus Del squared E.
It calls it here an identity.
Really, it's actually
the definition
of what this thing means.
And this is not obvious,
what this means, actually.
But these other
things, OK, they're
well defined, what they mean.
This thing is
actually just what it
says in Cartesian
coordinates, so you
know you've got Del is
equal to ddx in the I
direction, plus ddy
in the J direction,
plus dd zed in the K direction.
So Del squared is going
to be this dot this,
which is going to be d2 Del
squared equals d2, dx squared,
plus d2, dy squared,
plus d2, d zed squared.
And you'll notice that
that's exactly the same form
as the normal Laplacian, right?
So the lower
Laplacian you've had
before, Del squared of a
scalar, but this is different,
because this is Del
squared of a vector.
So what we're saying is that,
for Cartesian coordinates,
if we define Del squared
of a vector by this thing,
we find that it's got
exactly the same form
as Del squared of a scalar.
Now, that doesn't
actually work with
any other coordinate system,
so that's a bit of a warning.
If you go into sphericals
or cylindrical coordinates,
you'll find that this
Del squared of a vector
is not the same as
Del squared that you
would use for a scalar.
But nevertheless, let's do that.
We stick in this as being that.
And then we look
at this term here,
and mostly, we're going to be
interested in, for example,
regions where
there's no charges.
And very often,
also, we're going
to be interested
in isotropic media.
If these things are true, you
know that div D equals row,
so Div d is equal to naught
if there's no charges, which
means that Div E is equal to
naught if there's no charges,
and it's also isotropic.
So I'm saying this
all out in length
because you have to be very
careful about this, sometimes.
Div E equals naught is only
true if you've got no charges,
and it's an isotropic medium.
So if you've got, for example,
let's say a diffraction
grating, where you've got some
variations in permittivity,
then in general, you can't
actually assume this,
because epsilon is changing.
And therefore, with
div D equals naught,
div epsilon doesn't
equal naught.
But if you're in free space or
some constant isotopic medium,
this is true.
So this term goes,
and so this is just
equal to minus Del squared.
And so you can see then,
this Dell squared then
is just replaced by this, and
we got a sign change there.
So this is the final expression.
And you'll notice then
that this is exactly
the same form as the
normal wave equation
that we're very used
to in this scalar form,
except that the scalar
is replaced by a vector.
So that's really very nice.
Yeah, so comparing with
that wave equation,
this is the normal wave
equation we've had,
the scalar wave equation before,
and you can see then they're
exactly the same, except
that the scalar is
replaced by a vector.
And the one over
c squared, where
c is the velocity
of the wave, is
replaced by this thing,
so we can say then
that 1 over c squared is equal
to mu naught epsilon naught,
and that gives us then c is
1 over the square root of mu
naught epsilon naught.
And so here, there are
some figures put in,
and we get the expression for
the speed of light in vacuum.
So that's very neat.
I guess Maxwell must
have been really amazed
when he did this sum.
You don't know, of course, the
actual history of the thing,
but he played around with
these equations, didn't he?
And he came up with this
form which looked nicely
symmetrical to him.
And then he comes out with
an expression, comes out
with a value, for the speed
of light that it predicts,
which is what they
already knew was true.
So he must have felt
really as though he
was going to get the
Nobel Prize or something.
But probably, I
don't know-- maybe
it was before the Nobel
Prize, so quite interesting.
And actually, Naveen
was telling me
that he'd been looking at the
original paper by Maxwell.
Maxwell's equations, if you look
in the original, are horrible,
because he doesn't--
this terminology for vectors
wasn't invented then.
So it's done all in
terms of components,
horribly complicated.
And I think Naveen
said it was the--
Heaviside who actually really
derived the Maxwell's equations
in the form that we know
and love so well nowadays.
Heaviside you might remember,
he's famous for a few things,
but one of them
is a thing called
the Heaviside function, which
is basically a step function.
And the other thing is
the Heaviside layer,
which is an ionic
layer in the ionosphere
that he reflects
radio waves from.
OK, so that's all
about free space.
So how can we now
deal with matter?
Well, it turns out actually
there's lots of different ways
you can deal with--
lots of levels you can
deal with propagation
of electromagnetic
waves in matter.
You can, for example,
treat it really
from a proper atomic
point of view.
You can think of the
material being made up
of atoms which have got nuclei
and electrons clouds and so on.
Or you can think of
it in terms of matter
just being like an
isotropic material, where
you don't really go into
the microscopic view of it,
but just think of it
in a macroscopic way.
And actually, to some degree,
I think that, very often,
the second of those is just as
well, because normally, we're
not really interested in the
actual atomic nature of where
these properties come from.
But this is going back to how
you can think of it, really,
in terms of atoms.
So as you know,
atoms are made up
of a nucleus with
an electron cloud.
And the nucleus is
relatively fixed,
of course, because it's
heavy, but the electron cloud,
because the electrons
are much lighter,
can be moved around by
the field that's supplied.
So you get the distortion
of the electron cloud.
So this is what this
is showing here.
It's showing here
the nucleus here,
which is pretty well fixed,
because it's so heavy.
And then this
electron cloud, you
can think of it like being
joined to the nucleus
by a lot of springs.
And then the electrostatic--
the forces on that
electric cloud
caused by the electric field
will tend to, for example,
displace the electron cloud
relative to the nucleus.
So it gets sort of distorted.
And the way that's described is
in terms of a property called
the polarization then.
So this is showing how--
you can see that if you
move the negative charges
relative to the
positive charges,
you'll set up a sort
of dipole moment.
Separate the charges, you've
got a plus and a minus.
They're separated in distance,
so that acts like a dipole.
So that acts like a--
gives you a dipole
moment, and then
if you sum over all
those dipole moments,
you'll get the
total polarization
effects of applying that field.
So what that does then is
introduces these charge
variations, which distort
the charge that you really
have there, which is caused
by the bound charges.
So this is what we get.
You can say that
div D equals row,
so div E is equal to row over
epsilon naught, assuming the--
yeah, well, this is--
epsilon naught, of course,
is really a constant.
And we are breaking this up into
it's bound-and-free components,
and we're saying
that the free part--
we've got something wrong
with this again, haven't we?
Sorry, that should say--
that should say free
there, shouldn't it?
Yeah.
The free part and the
bound part is this part,
and so this is it,
the final result then.
We can now take the epsilon
naught the other side,
take this the other
side, and we get
the div of epsilon naught E plus
P is equal to the free charges,
right?
And then this thing
in brackets here
is what we call D, the
displacement in the medium.
So it's like if you've
got this medium,
div D equals row
is what we know is
the normal expression that we
write from Maxwell's equations.
And now, we've derived
that that D, in the medium,
can be written in terms of the
polarization of the molecules
that make up the medium.
So how do these things connect?
This shows us how
we do this then.
So we've got D equals
epsilon naught E plus P. Now,
in general, of course,
we don't really
know what this
does at the moment.
And in general, it can be
very complicated, actually.
It can be a non-linear
relationship
with the electric field.
But if I go back
again to the diagram,
you'll see that
this is a bit like--
you know, you've
got springs here.
Hooke's law tells
us, in mechanics,
if a system obeys Hooke's
law, then the extension
is proportional to the--
the tension is-- what is it?
Extension is proportional
to the attention.
Sorry, I'm not a
mechanical engineer,
so I don't know these things.
So you'd expect the same would
be true-- could be the same--
could be true here.
If you're only applying a
very weak field on here,
then you might think that this
relationship might be linear.
You'll get these springs
behaving like Hooke's law,
so you'll get a linear
relationship between P and D.
Now, also, in analogy with the
mechanical situation-- yeah?
STUDENT: So if we're in a
mat-- like in a material,
why is it the permitivity
of free space and not just
the permittivity
of the material?
Like why is it epsilon
naught and not epsilon?
COLIN SHEPPARD: Why is
it epsilon naught here
that you can write this?
This is either you can
think of as epsilon naught--
epsilon E, or you
can think of it
as epsilon naught
E plus P. So these
are two alternative
ways of looking
at the same thing, right?
So we've got D equals
epsilon naught E plus P,
and you can think of
this as being epsilon E.
So we're just about to carry
onto this on the next slide,
actually.
So that, you can see, tells us
that there is a relationship
now between epsilon
and P, right?
We're going to look what
that relationship is.
But in general, it's
actually quite complicated,
because we don't know the
relationship between P and E
yet, right?
So what I'm trying to
establish at the moment is
that if this thing--
if the fields are very
weak, then you'd expect,
maybe, a linear relationship.
P will be proportional
to E. So this term here
will also be something
times E, and so
you'll be able to take out
E as a factor from this.
Now, this is only going to be
true if this electric field is
weak compared with the--
you know, if the force
due to the electric field
is weak compared with the
forces involved in the binding
the electrons to the nucleus.
And I suppose it was probably
not until the invention
of the laser that probably
even people thought
you could ever
possibly get to a case
where that might not be true.
But now, of course, we
know, if you've got a laser,
you can make really big fields.
You can get, very easily,
into this rate regime where
this polarization changes.
And so you'll get
non-linear-type terms coming.
You're not going to do
this at all in the course.
But there is this
whole area, of course,
of non-linear optics, which is
when this linear approximation
breaks down.
So here we are.
So this is back to this, what
I said, D equals epsilon E. OK,
so that's really the
answer to your question.
And the D equals epsilon E, but
D equals this other expression,
epsilon naught E plus
P. And now, we say
that P is proportional to E.
This Chi is called the
electrics susceptibility,
which I think is a confusing
term because it's often,
in practice, just
called susceptibility.
People just neglect
the electric bit.
But of course, there is also
a magnetic susceptibility
which is very
important when you're
doing magnetic materials.
And unfortunately,
people use Chi for that
too, so that really gets people
confused if you're not careful.
So we're not going to be
doing anything with magnetism,
so maybe it's no problem for us.
But anyway, this is the
electric susceptibility.
So we can put in our P as
Chi E, and therefore, D
equals epsilon naught
1 plus Chi times E.
And this is equal to
epsilon E, as we've said.
And you can see then,
we have that epsilon
must equal this thing, epsilon
equals epsilon naught 1
plus Chi.
And this is a another
expression we've had before,
in terms of the refractive
index, so you can write
the permittivity, the
relative permittivity,
in terms of refractive
index, right?
So this is the refractive
index coming in here.
So under refractive index
then is the square root of 1
plus Chi.
And so you see how all
these things are connected.
You could also say,
one more, of course.
Where are we?
Yeah, we could
say that we've got
n squared equals
1 plus Chi, so Chi
is equal to n squared minus 1.
So this is another sort of form
you might come across at times.
You can see then, we
know in free space--
free space, n is 1,
so this thing is 0.
So there is no
polarization of free space,
which is what we know,
because there's nothing in it.
So there's nothing to polarize.
OK?
So, yeah, this bottom
bit just says that you
can do the same for magnetism.
You can do virtually the
same sort of expansions
for magnetism, but
we're not going
to deal with this, because
we're not going to deal
with magnetic materials at all.
But there are some
quite interesting,
you know, magneto optic
materials and so on,
which are quite
important actually,
nowadays, in terms of things
like optical data storage
and so on.
We're just going to be assuming
that, from the magnetic point
of view, the
material just behaves
exactly the same as free space,
so B equals mu naught H. Yeah?
STUDENT: The electric
polarization subtracts
the field out of the original.
Polarization adds the
field, magnetization
subtracts the field.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] has asked this
question of why this is a plus,
and this is a minus.
And the answer is,
I think it's all
to do with all these
horrible things you
learn about in magnetism, dire
magnetism and paramagnetism.
And sometimes, it's
whether they oppose
the change to which they were
due and all that sort of stuff.
So I think it's just
a case of whether--
if you define
magnetization in the way
that it's normally done, then it
turns out there's a minus sign,
but I think you could equally
well have defined it as being
the opposite side, actually.
Yeah.
I don't really know
much about magnetism,
so don't ask me too
much about that.
STUDENT: Also, I
think it has to do
with the part of
the stuff that--
B is actually the conjugate
of the electric displacement.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Ah.
STUDENT: So it includes the
effect of magnetization.
So another way to put it
is if you could please
go back one, if you
solve this, if you
take M to the other side,
then multiply it by mu naught,
then you'll get exactly
the question as before.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Of
course that's right.
If you just expand
this out, you get
B equals mu naught H
plus M, so it would
be exactly the same form then.
STUDENT: So the field
is actually H, not B.
The conjugate of the
electric field, E,
is the magnetic field, H,
not B. B is the induction.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah.
OK.
So now then, let's write down
those Maxwell's equations
for these various
different cases.
So this is how you can
write them in vacuum.
That's how we first
came across them.
And if you've got vacuum, and in
addition, you've got no charges
and no currents, then of course,
this term, this will be 0,
and this J will also be 0.
And now, you can see that
they look nicely symmetrical.
These two are both equal to 0,
and these things are both equal
to a first-- a time derivative,
but there is a difference
of a sine--
but apart from that,
nicely symmetrical.
And then the middle
row here says,
if you've got some
matter, and it's still
allowed to have free
charges and currents,
then we can write these things.
So this is what we
just said a minute ago.
Of course, if you've got no
free charges, then div D is 0.
And then if you've got
a material, matter,
without the free charges,
then again, we put the rows
in the J's, 0, and we end up
with these quite nice, simple,
and symmetrical sort
of relationships.
And in any of these
cases, of course,
you could derive
the wave equation
and write it in that same
form we had before, OK?
And as we said,
this term here is
related to the speed of light
in the medium, and what we find
is that the speed of
light in the medium
is equal to the speed of
light, your free space,
divided by the refractive index.
All of those things are
things we've had before.
So I'll just stress again,
one thing that I did
say earlier, this
was originally,
if you remember,
curl curl E. And then
when we got rid of
the curl curl E,
we actually had
to get rid of a--
what was it-- grad
of div E. And we
assumed that grad div E is 0.
I'm just reminding
you, again, that is not
always true, so beware.
And you probably won't come
across anything in this course,
but in the general wide
world, it's not always true.
And the second
thing to remember is
that this thing, Del squared of
a vector, that Del squared is
not equal to the
same as the Laplacian
except if you're in
Cartesian coordinates.
OK, so now we've got
the wave equation,
we go back just like we
did for scalar waves.
We could look at different
solutions of that wave
equation, and the
simplest possible one
is the equation of a plane wave.
And so this is a picture
of what it looks like.
I presume these pictures
are taken from [INAUDIBLE],,
but to me, it seems very
perverse to have the wave
propagating in the x direction.
He's a bit strange there, but
anyway, virtually every book
has the wave propagating
in the zed direction.
But nevermind, we
won't worry too much.
It obviously doesn't
make any difference.
But this is the important thing,
is we get the electric field
vector and the
magnetic field vector,
E and B he's drawing here.
It could equally well be
B and H, because the two--
the B and H are going to be
proportional to each other,
or at right angles
to each other.
I'm just telling you
the results first.
I haven't proved this yet.
And the wave is
propagating in a direction
which is at right
angles to both of those.
And so these three
form a triad, and it's
a right-handed triad
such that E cross B is
in the direction the wave goes.
So that's the way to
always remember it.
Well, that's the
way I remember it,
is that E cross B is in the
direction the field travels,
which means, of
course, if you've
got a right-hand
coordinate system,
normally, we would take
E in the x direction
and B in the y
direction, and then
the wave moves in
the zed direction.
But he's taken it with E in
the y direction like this,
in order to get it
so that it's still
a right-handed
coordinate system.
And so how do we get that?
Well, first of
all, of course, we
can say it's quite
straightforward for the E.
We can just solve
this thing for the--
just as a-- it's a scalar and
get an expression for E. E
is going to be then polarized
in a particular direction.
We've then got to work
out how B is polarized
for this particular
value of E. Well,
George has said
something here which is--
I guess it's correct, but
it's quite sort of condensed,
and I went through how I
would really derive it.
So perhaps, I'll say
a bit more about that.
Well, this first
part is all right.
We've got curl E is minus db dt.
And we know that the
time dependence is this e
to the minus i omega t.
So ddt of e to the minus i
omega t is very straightforward.
That's just-- the minus i
omega comes out the front.
So that's what we get.
Curl e is equal to minus db,
dt, is equal to i omega b.
And so we can say then
that b is equal to minus
i over omega curl e, all right?
So if we know what e is, we can
work out what b is from that.
And so we take e as being
this thing, all right?
So in general, this
might not be traveling
in the x direction or any
other particular direction.
It might be just pointing
in some direction in space.
So really, I guess,
you ought to do it
for that general
case, which means
that effectively
what you've got to do
is to work out what
curl of the e is.
And e is, effectively, as you
can see, a scalar quantity.
Well, let's forget about
the time dependence.
We're only looking
at the space now.
There's this scalar
quantity here.
Time is a constant vector.
So we then have to use another
of our identities, which
is the curl of a
scalar times a vector.
So let's write it like that.
And you might remember that that
is equal to-- and I had to look
it up because I never
know these things--
5 times curl a plus grad
phi across a, all right?
So that is a general
vector identity
which allows you to work out
the curl of this product of two
things.
And in our case,
this is a plane wave.
So this direction of the
e vector is constant.
So our a is a constant.
So curl of a is going to
be 0 because it's constant.
So that goes.
And we're then left with
the curl of phi times a
is grad phi cross a.
And phi is equal to-- phi
equals e to the i k dot r.
And a is equal to this direction
of the e vector, all right?
So if phi equals e
to the i k dot r,
then grad phi is equal to
ik times e to the i k dot r.
And so we stick that into here.
And after we've done that,
we can derive this expression
here.
We find that finally
the magnetic vector
is equal to the cross
products of these two.
So that's why, of course,
all these three things
have to be right angles
to each other, all right?
So the next thing,
this is a picture of it
moving along then.
And we'll stress, very
strongly, something.
And that is that these two, the
electric and magnetic field,
are in phase with each other.
I don't know what it
is, but I've often
found that students don't
seem to pick this up.
And they come up with
these funny ideas
about them being in quadrature.
And I think they get it mixed
up with some other things.
But for a plane polarized
wave, the electric field
and the magnetic
field, you can see,
are in phase with each other.
When the e is a maximum,
the b is a maximum.
And then they will
have this wave form.
Here this is showing the wave
as a function of distance.
This is like a snapshot of what
happens at a particular time.
But you could equally well get
a very similar sort of thing
by looking at a
particular position
and seeing how it
changes with time.
You'd also get sine
waves like this.
And you would also
see that these two,
the electric and
magnetic fields,
have to be in phase with each
other for that case, too.
OK?
This is expressing--
showing you, again,
this right-hand rule
or whatever it is for--
I don't know how
you do these things.
But anyway, I always like the--
I can never do these, partly
because I'm left-handed,
I think.
It ruins things.
But this corkscrew
rule is the one
that I always know that one.
And my students will
know it's because I'm
very handy with a corkscrew.
[LAUGHS]
So this is showing, then, how
this electric field varies
with space, the fixed time.
And the distance, then,
between these maxima
in the electric field is
the wavelength, all right?
So this is going to propagate.
It's a traveling wave.
So this structure moves
bodily, doesn't it,
in time along this
direction of propagation.
Ah, and now we get
onto this thing
that I was talking with George
about on the way, the Poynting
vector.
And I don't think you actually
really sort of prove it,
do you, what it really does.
But basically the Poynting
vector, it turns out,
is a measure of the energy flow.
So it's a way of looking
at the energy that's
carried by a wave.
And this is the
definition of it.
So s is equal to 1
over mu 0, e cross b.
Actually, you can see b equals--
actually, I think this should
really be mu, shouldn't it,
not mu 0, really, if it
was in a general medium.
And b equals mu h, of course.
So this is really cross h.
So that's the way it's sometimes
derived, sometimes defined.
But anyway, but if you're
in free space, then
you can write it with
mu 0 here like that.
And then, using our expression
for the velocity of light,
then we can write it like this.
But I think this is also
true for free space only.
I think that's right.
Presumably this is
from Hecht again.
OK, so this is what
our waves look like.
Each of electric and magnetic
fields is a cosine-type wave.
So this represents,
then, a wave which
is moving in this
direction, all right?
So this thing in here basically
is the phase, isn't it?
You got cos of a phase term.
So you can see that
as omega t varies,
so the shape of
the wave is going
to sort of move in a
particular direction.
And you'll notice that--
oh, this is a vector.
This is a vector, but
this is a constant vector.
So this is a vector
which tells you
the amplitude of that wave
in magnitude and direction.
And you'll notice
that these cosine bits
are exactly the same.
That's because, as we
said, the e and the b
are in phase with each other.
And so all that's very simple.
And so what we can say
is that if we represent
the fields like this,
we can say, according
to our definition of
the Poynting vector,
we can write it like this.
And so we end up, then, cos
times cos is cos squared.
So notice that, although cos
of course can go negative,
it's periodic, isn't it?
So it's negative half as
long as it's positive.
Cos squared is always positive.
So the way this is defined,
the Poynting vector
is always going in
the same direction.
It's always, when
you've got a plane wave,
the energy is going in the
direction of the direction
of propagation of the wave.
And OK, so this shows
us how we get all this.
Sorry, let me-- this shows us--
can I go back?
Aw, yeah.
Oh, I've gone back too far now.
Here we are.
This shows us how this
Poynting vector varies
in space and time, all right?
So this Poynting vector has also
got a sort of wave-type nature.
But normally what
we're interested in
is not how it varies
in space and time,
but what the time-averaged form
of that is going to look like.
And so we can do a
time average of it.
And so that's what
this thing here is.
This s with the lines on either
side is the time average of s.
And so we've got b is
k times e over omega.
And so therefore we've
got here e cross b.
And we know what b is.
So we can put that in.
And we're going to
get now e squared.
All right, so
finally what we get
is that the Poynting vector
is proportional to the time
average of the
electric field squared.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Let's
take the average.
We haven't done the average.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Oh, we
haven't done any average yet.
Sorry, but this is the modulus.
So--
AUDIENCE: Anyway [INAUDIBLE].
COLIN SHEPPARD: It's the--
AUDIENCE: So right now--
COLIN SHEPPARD: What
do the two lines mean?
AUDIENCE: The magnitude
of the vector.
COLIN SHEPPARD: OK, it's
the magnitude of the vector.
AUDIENCE: A function of time.
COLIN SHEPPARD: It's
still a function of time.
OK, we'll take it as that, yeah.
And yeah, OK.
And I think, really,
if it's in a medium,
this is epsilon, not epsilon 0.
Is that right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah.
OK, so now we're going
to do the time averaging.
So this e, e is a
time-varying quantity.
e varies with both
space and time.
And so this is the modular
square of it, of the vector.
So we put that in.
And we get, then, the s is equal
to something we cos squared.
So it's not much different
from what we had before.
OK, and then the next thing we
do is to do the time averaging.
So this is something which
is positive but oscillating,
time-varying.
And the speed of these
variations is very, very fast.
We've said before the
frequency of light is around 10
to the 15 Hertz, which is
faster than any detector
that we have to measure the
fields directly, all right?
So you can't actually
measure the electric field
or the power of an optical
wave because the frequency's
so high.
So a normal detector, like
a photo diode or whatever,
would be measuring some
time average of this
because there's no
way it can respond
to this sort of frequency.
So we do the time average.
And so this is how we can
do the time average, right?
The square things mean time
average, the caret signs.
And the time average, you
integrate this over a long time
and divide by the time
to get the time average.
And so this is called--
well, usually called intensity.
I think that "intensity" is
now frowned upon by purists.
And they come up with new
names every now and then.
So "irradiance" is a word
that you often read nowadays
in the literature.
And yeah, so here
it's measured in watts
per square meter, which is
obviously a unit of power
density, all right?
There's one other thing
that's worth mentioning here.
And that is actually that
normal detectors actually really
don't measure the
Poynting vector.
They actually usually measure
the electric energy density.
And there's a thing called
Poynting's theorem, which,
if you study
electromagnetism, will
show that the power
flow out of a volume
is equal to the rate of
change of the stored energy.
And the stored
energy is made up of
electric and magnetic energy.
So all these things are related.
And it turns out that for all
practical purposes normally
it doesn't really matter whether
you're measuring the Poynting
vector or the electric
energy density or whatever.
It's going to give the
same sort of answer.
But there are cases where
you have to be careful.
OK, and then finally we've got
to do this time average of cos
squared.
And the time average of
cos squared is just a half.
You remember how you do that?
Cos squared, you go
into double angles.
And then you get a
cosine that cancels out.
And you're just left
with the constant bit.
And then, finally then,
you put that half in.
And we've now got an
expression for the intensity,
defined as being the time
average of the Poynting vector
as being equal to the amplitude
of the electric field squared,
multiplied by some
constant, which,
in probably 99 cases out
of 100, we don't even
bother to even think
what that constant
is, let alone thinking of
whether there's a half there.
So you'll see loads
of books or papers
where they just say
that the intensity is
equal to e squared, which is
strictly not true, I guess,
but people do say.
So how are we going?
We got one hour, yeah.
OK, so that's how you
can calculate the power
flow for a plane wave.
I guess the method
is not only going
to be true for plane waves.
But you can apply it for
other sorts of waves, too.
But the next thing is you
might think back to what
we were doing with phases.
And there are a
few things that are
important to realize
here, what you can do
and what you can't do.
You remember this is what
we said from our phases.
We said that what we actually
measure in the real world
is a wave that's like this.
It's a cosine dependence
in space and time.
And we say that we use
this complex representative
where we say that
this is the real part
of some complex exponential.
And if you remember, the
reason for doing that
is that these
complex exponentials
are much easier to manipulate.
It means that you don't have to
remember all those horrible cos
of a plus b things and so on.
So it's much easier to do
the algebra using these.
So what you do normally,
as you remember,
is you do all your algebra
with each of the i-somethings.
And then right at the
very end normally,
you find the real
part to find what
the real field is in real
space, as we're used to.
But here, now you've got to
be very careful because you
saw that the Poynting vector
actually was cos squared,
all right?
So this is a nonlinear.
We performed a
nonlinear operation.
And if you do
nonlinear operations,
the same would be true
for nonlinear optics,
as well, actually.
You can't do it in
this complex notation
directly because you just
get the wrong answer.
If you squared this, you get
an e to the 2i kz minus 5,
wouldn't you?
Now the real part of
that is not what we want.
So what you've really got to do
is to work through, I guess--
well, the surest way of doing
it is to work through in terms
of the cosines and so on rather
than to go into e to the i's.
So this is saying a
bit more about this.
So what we've got, then, is this
is showing how you can do it
in terms of the cosines.
So you can see that,
for example, here we've
got two fields.
And let's say that
you see the point is
that, although the
fields are additive,
the power of those
two waves is not
going to be equal to the sum
of the powers of the two waves,
all right?
So we can say that the
e's would add coherently.
And then we can work
out the power flow
of the sum of these two fields.
And you can see of course,
expanding this square,
you're going to have
the power of the two.
But you're also going
to get this cross term,
the cross product
term, which depends--
you can see here--
on the relative phase
of the two waves.
If they're out of
phase by 90 degrees,
then that will go to 0.
But if they're in phase, this
of course is going to be strong.
And so that's one
way of doing it.
But in terms of
phases, then, you
can do it in terms of phases.
I'm just saying you have to
be careful how you do it.
And so you have to add the
phases first and then find
the modulus square.
You can't actually
do the squaring
and then do the real
power, all right?
So you add these
two phases together,
which gives the total field.
And then the intensity
is going to be
the modulus square of this.
And you expand it.
And you can see we've got
exactly the same answer.
So it doesn't matter
which way you do it,
as long as you do it
one of those ways.
What you don't want to do is
to try squaring the e-to-the-i
things and then taking the
real power because you'll get
something different then.
And that is the very last slide.
And that is dead on time.
So, well, whoa,
we've got a couple
of minutes for some questions.
So any questions?
Yes, Sharon?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Hello?
I'm quite curious about
the Poynting vector.
And you mentioned that
it's actually a cross term,
and it's similar like
propagation and direction,
like where the energy flows.
But what about the peculiar
case in evanescent waves?
Does it mean the energy
is not propagating there?
COLIN SHEPPARD: Oh, oh, dear.
Oh, yes.
Evanescent waves, you're
getting onto something
really controversial--
AUDIENCE: No, I'm thinking--
COLIN SHEPPARD:
--here, I think--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
COLIN SHEPPARD: --actually.
AUDIENCE: Well, where
has the energy gone then?
COLIN SHEPPARD: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: I mean, if
the Poynting vector is
the direction of
the energy flow,
then it seems like there's
no propagation in energy
in the evanescent wave then--
COLIN SHEPPARD:
Well, it is normally
said that there is
no energy propagation
in an evanescent wave.
But you know, in
a way, there is.
There's sort of transverse
propagation of energy.
But there's no
energy flow across--
if you're doing total
internal reflection
and you're looking
at the steady state,
there's no energy flow
across the boundary,
I think is true to say.
Is that true, or--
yeah, this is--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yes.
COLIN SHEPPARD: --getting a
bit controversial, isn't it?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Yes, you can--
if you have the interface--
I don't know if anyone
can see, but if you
have the interface of the TAR,
if you compute the Poynting
vector in the vertical
direction, those have to be 0.
The time average is 0.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah, yeah.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: So
you don't have energy flow.
But you do have energy density.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah, yeah.
And the other
thing is, you know,
the question of if
you've got-- and this is
your total internal reflection.
So here you get this
evanescent wave.
Now, of course,
all these questions
of these evanescent
waves and so on, they all
rely on assuming infinite plane
waves and infinite surfaces
and things like that, which
of course none of these things
can really be strictly
true in practice.
But if we do this,
then we'd expect
to get something
which is actually
traveling in this direction.
And so in some sense,
I think that there
is some sort of energy flow
in the transverse direction.
But I'm just having a big
argument about this, not
for this case, but to do
with some other project
we're doing at the
moment where it's
to do with when
the h vector is 0.
And so the question is,
is there energy flow?
Well, I guess there isn't.
But I think there's
also this question
of whether Poynting vector
really always means the energy
flow.
In fact, I remember having a
conversation with Emil Wolf
once about this.
And, well, he said, let
me give you an example.
Imagine you have a DC
planar electric field
in this direction, and you
have a DC planar magnetic field
in this direction.
Is there any energy flow?
No.
But you can work out
what e cross h is.
And you know, so I think
that he put this forward
as an example which makes you
wonder whether it necessarily
really always means energy flow.
We were talking
about this in the lab
today because
people have come up
with these solutions where, for
example, energy flow sometimes
does this.
So you might get the lines of--
the Poynting vector might
do something like this.
So here you can
see that there has
to be some sort of 0 around here
because this is going this way,
and this is going this way.
And here you can actually
get these, sort of,
closed eddies of Poynting vector
that's going round in circles.
Now, whether this
really represents
something that's physical
or not, I don't really know.
You know, in water flow, I
guess you could get this.
There's no reason why
you couldn't get eddies
of water going in circles.
But you know, so
this is what you get.
This is what you
get if you've just
got a very simple example of
a lens focusing the light.
You get this sort of pattern if
I look at this in some detail.
You get this sort of
behavior in this region here.
And there've been papers
that have described this.
But what it really
means in practice--
well, I guess nothing
really means anything
unless you can measure it.
So the question
is, can you come up
with a detector that
measures Poynting vector?
And I don't know
the answer to that.
As I said earlier, I think
normally detectors measure
electric energy density.
So people have looked at
what happens in this focused
region of a lens.
And there are various
ways you can look at that.
People have used
near-field optics,
you know, a tapered
fiber to look at it.
Or you can do some sort of
tomography-type experiments
with a detector that you
rotate and things like that.
But to actually measure the
Poynting vector, I don't know.
Right, any questions
from over there?